even though it's been a decade since the
original zombie lands the wild ride
across the country is far from over for
devoted fans who have been waiting for
years and for anyone just now
discovering the first film let's look at
everything we know about zombie land to
double tap this horror comedy sequel is
currently scheduled to come out on
October 18th 2019 that makes perfect
sense as that would be just 13 days
before Halloween and there's another
good reason for that particular release
date the first zombie land caught into
theatres on October 9th 2009 so the
sequel is poised to come out right
around the 1 decade anniversary there
should be an ideal trying to check out
weather for survivors landed after so
many years on the road as a highly
dysfunctional zombie busting family
originally October 11th was pegged as a
release date but it was pushed back a
week where it will be up against
Maleficent mistress of evil if Columbus
and Tallahassee can defeat the undead
we're pretty sure they'll be able to
hold their own against Angelina Jolie as
well Emma Stone Abigail Breslin Woody
Harrelson and Jesse Eisenberg are all
set to reprise their roles which means
our four heroes stoked to their survival
roles and made it through the last
decade in one piece and Bill Murray has
even reportedly coming back which
doesn't make a lick of sense as he
spoiler alert met his unfortunate and
hilarious demise in the first movie
every way who's Bill Murray yeah I've
never had a kid before I mean that's
like asking who Gandhi is who's Gandhi
but that lapse in logic will be worth it
as Murray is also bringing along his
Ghostbusters buddy dan Aykroyd and
that's not the only new addition Avan
Jogia will be playing Berkeley a bad-boy
musician and Zuri Deutsch and rosario
Dawson show up as a couple of characters
named Madison and Nevada respectively
and finally Luke Wilson and Thomas
Middleditch will also be joining in on
the fun
with all that talent assembled we're
expecting a thoroughly entertaining
sequel plot details for Zombieland two
of the sphe are being kept in the wraps
but we do know that it takes place ten
years after the original and the zombies
are way more dangerous than before
according to The Hollywood Reporter the
sequel send the main quartet from the
White House to the American heartland as
a face-off against new kinds of zombies
that have evolved since the first zombie
land as well as some new human survivors
they will
laughter face the growing pains of their
snarky makeshift family it's clear that
everyone involved is excited for part
two but when it comes to quality sequels
have often failed miserably in the past
fortunately for nervous Zombieland fans
Jesse Eisenberg believes as involvement
in the movie should come as a sign that
something good is brewing he told the
Toronto Sun we would never have made
another one if we didn't think it was
going to be great
they wrote a ton of scripts for this
movie and we went through a lot of
different ideas finally we have
something I think people are going to
love and they must own discuss the
importance of the cast camaraderie
during an appearance on The Tonight Show
Jesse Eisenberg and Woody Harrelson's
Lana it would so yeah it was so much fun
we played a lot of games yeah our ping
pong a lot of pool more games the
returning filmmaking talent also extends
behind the camera for Zombieland to
ruben fleischer is coming cause of the
heels of helming venom as he settles
into the director's chair for double tab
plus original writers Paul Wernick and
Rhett Reese are also coming back they
too have been pretty busy in the last
few years as they're the minds behind
the Deadpool franchise while nothing has
confirmed the gap in time is expected to
play a large part in Wernick and Reese's
story and Fletcher wants everyone to
know that zombieland creative team
waited so long for a sequel because they
wanted to ensure that they had a good
idea as he told latino-review media I'm
proud to say I think our script is
really great and that the movie will be
as good as the original if not better
and that's why we're all back that these
fans the Zombieland marketing team took
advantage of the 10 year challenge meme
that went viral recently to announce the
film's official title and show the cast
together again for the first time in the
image shared on the official Zombieland
Twitter account in January 2019
Harrelson Eisenberg stone and Breslin
recreated their poses from the first
film's poster this time around
obviously that all 10 years older even
if a few of them don't look it and
surprisingly president looks the most
different of the bunch as the 23 year
old actress was only 13 when the
original hit theatres but we imagine
that most of the crew has the same old
attitudes even without the 10 year
challenge reminding us how much things
stay the same then on July 21st 2019 the
first DoubleTap trailer arrived online
the clip suggests at this unlikely units
are settled into a comfortable life as a
family they're even making strides
toward normalcy as evidenced by a bit of
a Christmas celebration
things are thrown out of whack when the
zombie survivors must adapt to the
newcomers among the living check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos but your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel enter the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]